we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p i got a very
interesting and nice voicemail from
jordan Peterson with some advice for my
now earlier in the week appearance on
the Joe Rogan program take off take a
listen to this warning from Jordan
Peterson hi David this is Jordan B
Peterson calling in I just wanted to
call because I heard the exciting news
that you might be on the tool rock and
podcast later this week so
congratulations on that and just wanted
to call and also say take you know make
sure you study up before you go on there
because I did it myself and um I didn't
have all my like ideas entirely coherent
in my head and I realized after work
when I watched the video that I just
said a whole lot of gobbledygook and Joe
Rogan who seems just like a STONER
comedian type actually got made a lot
more sense than I did okay so uh that's
my advice and again congratulations okay
I'm gonna take a buy now okay okay my
boy okay so very good Jordan Peterson of
course is Canadian not Irish and that
started sounding a little bit Irish in
some places we've got a great bonus show
for you today I'll tell some
behind-the-scenes stories from my trip
to LA we'll talk about the Boston
straight Pride Parade lovely city and we
will also talk about whether a school
officer should be jailed for child
neglect all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show it's a great time to
support the shows that you enjoy that
you think are important as we have a
growing ad pocalypse 3.0 ad boycotts and
so many other things WW join pakman.com
it is very easy to become a member it
takes under one minute and you can save
40% if you want by using the coupon code
this is 20 20 that'll save you 40% off
of the membership of your choice